abone ol
mi Evet bugün keşifleri konuşacağız
İnsanın en büyük Tutkusu keşif keşfetmek
yeni coğrafyalar yeni gezegenler Yeni
insanlar Hatta yeni kuşaklar Bugün de
konuştuğumuz gibi söylediğim gibi
keşifleri kuşakları konuşacağız dedik
Aslında kuşaklar bizim gündemimizde ilk
ne zaman geldi hatırlayınız var mı mı
2013 yılı Gezi olaylarıyla birlikte
bizim ülkemizi Bir Kuşak y kuşağına
ilişkin bir şeyler söylenmeye başladım y
kuşağı bu çocuklar nereden çıktı
nerelerde ne yapıyorlar O zaman
tekrarlamaya başlandı y kuşağı Çünkü
aslında hiç olmamış şeyleri yapıyordu o
güne kadar Çünkü biz onları Aslında
apolitika sosyal Toplumsal olaylara
duyarsız
şu an Ne diyorduk Bu arada Gezi olayları
demişken birinciden bahsediyorum sonraki
provokatörler den değil Onun da altında
özellikle çizdiğim Gerçekten samimiyetle
çevre duygusuna mücadele veren
gençlerden bahsediyorum Evet
sorguluyorlar the 70a İngilizce'de Vay
yani şu lise İngilizce denize bir
dönersek neden niçin anlamına gelen
Bu bir anlam taşıyor ve biz de aslında y
kuşağına hep sorgulayan diyoruz ya belki
de buradan geliyor Biz tabi Hep onlardan
bahsederken diye kuşağından Ve
sorguladık larından ve ne olacak bu
gençliği hallederken Aslında bizden daha
öncelerde bu da sorgulanmış başkaları da
sorgulamış mesela bu sözü kim söylemiş
olabilir Sizce bugünün gençleri lüks ve
gösteriş düşkünü saygısız başkaldıran
Gebze doyumsuzdur bir y kuşağı tanımı
gibi değil mi bu
bu söyleyen Sokrates milattan önce
1469 399
Bu bir başka söz daha geliyor şimdi
Bugünlerde gençler kontrolden çıkmış
durumda kabul bir şekilde yemek yiyorlar
yetişkinlere karşı saygısızlar eve
beyinlerine karşı çıkıyorlar ve
öğretmenlerini sinirlendiriyor lar barz
e tuşu alabilir mi
Ben bunu söyleyen kim acaba bunu
söyleyenler İso ve milattan önce 384 322
arasında yaşamış
O biraz daha ileri gidiyorum şimdi bir
başka ifade var gençlerle ilgili O da şu
bu şu şu gençliğin hali ne olacak Tam da
bu günün sözü değil mi Bu çok daha
enteresan bunu da söyleyenler
bu süper çiviyazıları milattan önce
2000-3500 yılları arasında Yani aslında
değişen hiçbir şey yok şu
bu Türkiye'de Kuşaklar
bu Deniz hocamın da bahsettik ve asla
sonun yüz son 30-40 yıl da söyleniyor da
son Yüzyıl'ı kapsıyor belki 1920'li
yıllarda başlayıp sessiz kuşak bebek
patlaması sonrasında ksusha y&z olarak
şekilleniyor şimdi Gökhan tabi ablam
falan dedi böyle biraz gelmeden önce
hafif bir panzer Winx kuşağım ama
sonlarına doğru olanlardan Hani suçlar
değil yanlış anlaşılmasın y64t başlayıp
80'de bitiyor biliyorsunuz Ben 80'e çok
yakınım Hayır
çok az daha şey olsa olacaktır Şimdi x
kuşağı et diye okunuyor İngilizce'de exe
duymuşsunuzdur değil mi Evet Sorma kek
saçlı falan eski bitmiş kayıp ölmüş Biz
atfedilen de bu
Evet şimdi hal böyle olunca biz tabi
sorgulayan Bir Kuşak olamadık olmamızın
sebebi aslında bizi yetiştiren bebek
patlaması ve sessiz kuşak siyasi olarak
o kadar yorulmuş ki bir süre ihtilal
yaşamış işte acılar çekmiş ideolojisi
yüzünden hapishanelerde çürümüş vesaire
vesaire ve dönmüş çocuklarına demiş ki
Aman gözünü seveyim hiçbir olaya karışma
Sen Okulu'na git gel Ben her türlü
imkanı sağlarım ama sadece okul işini
yap başka hiçbir şey yapma işte biz o
kuşaktan geliyoruz ilk su şak dediğimiz
her şartta Tüm bu baskılara rağmen
ayakta kalmayı başaran bir diğer tabirle
Survivor kuşağı dediğimizi kuşak
törpülenmiş törpülenmiş törpülenmiş
Hatta kendinden anne-babadan törpülenmiş
sonra çocuk sahibi olmuş çocuklar bizden
Doğan
o z kuşağı onların aşırı bir baskısı var
üzerimizde kalıyoruz Çünkü arada müthiş
bir kuşak farkı var onlardan da torpil
endik öbüründen de torpil endik arada
böyle Zavallı Bir Kuşak olarak kaldık
Hatta şunu
o yeşil hemen şöyle bir ifadeyle Aslında
ilk kuşağını Anlamak mümkün kaynanaların
Zalim olduğu gelinlerin dönemde gelin
gelinleri Zalim olduğu dönemde kaynama
aylık diyor ksusha Şimdi benim
Kayınvalidem de burada lütfen yanlış
anlama bu ama böyle bir deryasını Varex
uşağının maalesef
Evet şimdi kuş Koşun var mı insanları
oluşturuyor acaba insanlar mı koşulları
en temel sorulardan bir tanesi bu
aslında
ama biz gerçekten maruz kaldığımız şeyi
yaşıyoruz Yani şartlar mı böyle yoksa
birileri o şartları oluşturuyor mu
1980'li yıllarda başlayan dünyadaki o
küreselleşme hareketi alan hâkimiyetinin
yeri yani büyük coğrafyalara sahip olan
ülkelerin hakimiyetini kaybedip pazar
hakimiyeti söz konusu olduğu ekonominin
her şeyin önüne geçtiği Hatta
devletlerin bile önemini yitirip
şirketlerin çok önem kazandığı bir
sürece girdik şifre otokrasi diye bir
terim girdi bizim lügatları mıza yani
demokrasi bürokrasinin yerine artık
şirketlerin hakim olduğu bir süreçten
bahseder olduk E tabi şirketler öyle bir
halde der ki dünyadaki birçok ülkeden
büyükler ve sürekli üretiyorlar
üretiyorlar üretiyordu üretiyorlar bu
ürettiklerini talep edecek bir kitle
oluşturmanın lazım Bu talebe
oluşturmaları lazım
da mutlaka hepinizi şahit olmuşsunuzdur
gel şahit olmuşsunuzdur derken bu
salondaki herhalde yüzde yetmiş kişinin
elinde vardır iPhone cep telefonu
iPhone'u nin yaratıcısı yapan Steve
Johnson hiç unutamadığım bir sözü var
der ki insanlar bir şey istemezler
Ama siz insanlara insan hiçbir şeye
ihtiyaç duymazlar Siz insanlara ona
ihtiyaç duyduğu vurursanız ancak var
olursunuz bizim aslında bir şey
istediğiniz bir şey ihtiyaç duyduğumuz
falan yoktu ama öyle bir hale geldi ki
ihtiyaç duymamız konusunda Biz
şartlandırılmış IQ ve Dedeler geçti Siz
şu kuşaktan sanız şöyle tüketirsiniz
şunları alırsınız şunları giyersiniz
şunları dinlersiniz şu kuşaktan sana
sizin algılarımız farklıdır alışveriş
şeklini farklı aşık olmanız farklıdır
sosyal medyada olmanız farklıdır şimdi
bu 60'lı 50'li 60'lı yaşlar Facebook'ta
onun biraz daha altı Instagram'da daha
adları tek nokta değil mi öyle biliyorum
var ya orada bile bir ayrışma söz konusu
orada ile dayatılan bir şey var aslında
ve Ben kızımı ya da olma Facebook'la
ilgili bir şey söyleme Facebook Hani
oraları bile geçmişler çoktan şimdi bu
ilk kuşağı ile ilgili biz öyle bir
kuşaklı ki ilk kuşağı olarak bak annem
geldi bana ben yemek yediğim zaman fil
avında tabağında pilav bırakma bıraktım
Pirinç tanesi kadar çocuğun olur şimdi
ben buna inandırdım O yüzden yemeyeceğim
pilavı bile yer şu iki tane falan
bırakırdım
Sen kendini gerçekleştiren Kehanet Allah
bana iki tane de çocuk nasip etti İki
pilav iki çocuklar bunun zaman
sorgulamadım yani Nasıl ne alaka falan
değil böyle bir şey aklıma gelmedi Şimdi
ben böyle birşey çocuklara söylediğimde
hani böyle bir girişimi oldu Birkaç kere
Ha ha ha Nasıl ya falan diyorlar Hatta
bir kere B olan düştü Bir gün ben dedim
ki Ay anneciğim öpeyim de geçsin oğlumu
Bana verdiği Cevap şuydu dört yaşında
çok felsefik bir cevap anne acılar
öpmeyle geçmez dedi
Sen neyle geçer dedim yara bandıyla dedi
Şimdi tabi buralardan baktığımızda Hani
o eksi kuşağı
en iyi Tabi biz bu Küreselleşmenin Hatta
küreselleşme dememek lazım Bunun adına
küreselleştirme nin Çünkü birilerinin
eliyle sosyal mühendislik ve yapılan bir
şey ve kullandıkları çok tehlikeli
silahlar var Eğitim iletişim teknoloji
ve Sözüm Ona medenileşme adına
yaptıkları bir takım algı yönetimleri
bunlarla bizim algılarımız da
alışkanlıklarım ızla sevgilerimizle
nasıl aşık olunacağını anası
evleneceğine nasıl bir hayat
yaşanacağına dair her şeyini önümüzde
sunan bir sistemden bahseder olduk
Evet şimdi tabi işim bu boyutu koşullar
mı insanları insanlarla koşulları bana
soracak olursanız Aslında İkisininde
cevabı evet yani kuşaklar Külliyen
yoktur da Diyemem çünkü üzerinde
çalışılan ve ciddi bulgular da olan bir
teori olduğunu düşünüyorum ama kuşaklar
vardır ve bunlar da burçlar gibi aylara
göre insanlara özellikler yıllara göre
atfeder ve buna göre de insanlar böyle
davranır herax kuşağı böyledir her y
kuşağı böyledir diyemeyiz şimdi y kuşağı
için Diyoruz ki biz 80'den sonra
Doğanlar mm yılına kadar ettim şeyler
birazcık daha böyle rahatlarına düşkün
leriche anlayışları iç kuşağına göre çok
farklı ve Çünkü yaşamak için biz çalın
yaşamak için çalışıyorduk onlar Bizden
çok daha farklı yaşıyorlar hayatım
hayatımla ilgili bizden daha belirgin
bir algıları var
mı böyle sürekli olumsuz tarafından
baktığımızda bize benzemeyen öteki
eleştirdiğimiz bir süreçten Elbette
bizden sonra gelenler ile ilgili
söyleyeceklerimiz de bunun benzeri
olacak çünkü Tıpkı aristokrates ya da
sümerlerin söylediği gibi şimdi bugün
size Aslında iki tane haber vermek
istiyorum kuşaklarla ilgili bir tanesi
şu kuşaklar yüzyılda bir başa dönüyor
Yani bu şu demek ki
Evet Ee hani en çok eleştirilen ve
üzerinde durulan y kuşağı var ya
sabırsız dik başlığı sorgulayan
dediğimiz diye kuşağı Yüzyıl geriye
gidelim lütfen 1980'den 1881 gidelim ve
o tarihlerde doğmuş birini söyleyin bana
1881'den Mustafa Kemal Atatürk bu
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk bu hesaba göre y
kuşağı sorguluyor muyduk
Bu sorguluyor da
ve dikbaşlı mıydı Evet askeri o sicil
defterlerinde diyor ki elde tutulması
çok zor sürekli sorgulayan çok meraklı
dikbaşlı İpek'i otoriteye karşı mıydı
Evet örgütlenme ile ilgili ikiye
kuşağına yine atfedilen özelliklerden
bir tanesi yeteneği var mıydı Kesinlikle
evet ve iyi ki de vardı biliyor musunuz
şu Z şimdi o sorgulayan çok meraklı
mi eğer otorite ile Doğru olmayan şey
konusunda mücadele eden bir y kuşağı
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti'nin kurulmasını
sağladı Biz şimdi en çok eleştirdiğimiz
y kuşağının ne yapacağımı Elif'in çok
fazla fikrimiz yok bu Ön yargı ile
ilgili Bence biraz onu cebimize koyalım
bize kuşağına Gelecek olursak Yani bu
bizim ilk kuşağının ol mantıklı
çocukları acılar akma ile geçmez diyen
çocukları ne olacak derseniz işte
Yüzyıllık döngüde diyor ki sizin Z
kuşağı çocuklarınızda sizin dedeleriniz
Hatta dedelerinizin babası gibi be
erleri önem veren
Bu felsefe yapan aile kavramına düşkün
gençler olacak süper beraber değil mi en
çok korktuğumuz yozlaştı ını
düşündüğümüz Eğer kuşaklar teorisi
doğruysa böyle bir sonuç bekliyoruz
diyelim ki Külliyen Hepsi yanlış Az önce
Çağlayan hocam burada çok güzel şarkılar
söyle bir ilk söylediği şarkı neydi
O Benim Sadık Yarim Kara Topraktır ve
onu kavur yapmış değil mi bambaşka bir
soufa söyledi bize ama hepimiz eşlik
ettik 50 yıl önce Veysel söylediğinde
eşlik eden insanlar 50 yıl sonra burada
y kuşağı zeytinyağı 3 tuşa hep birlikte
aynı türkü söyleye bilmenin keyfini
yaşadık belki durumlar biraz şekil
değiştirir ama Öz hep aynıdır biz yeter
ki üzün sağlam tutmaya devam edelim ve
en önemli bence mesajlardan biri bu
gençlere B hayatlarındaki diğer
konuşmacıları mızda hep vurgu yaptığı
hayatlarının gerçekten anlamlı bir araca
bağlı olmasın eğer biz onlara insanları
sevmeyi dünyaya duyarlı olmayı
dürüstlüğü yaptıkları işi iyi yapmayı bu
vatanı sevmeyi ve hoşgörülü olmayı
üretirsek korkulacak hiçbir şey yok Coco
bu Gönlünüz rahat olsun Bugün bu
şarkılarla ilgili İnşallah daha gelecek
vadeden konuşmalar dinlemeyi uyuyor
hepinizi saygıyla selamlarım